okay so the topic of this video will be
the process of dehydration synthesis
versus hydrolysis let's get started
so let's start in the blue area with
dehydration synthesis it's a chemical
reaction it's going to bond multiple
monomers into a single larger polymer
monomers are just building blocks small
carbon organic building blocks and in my
animation I've got three
hexagons labeled the word monomer
and what we see here is in a dehydration
synthesis reaction two monomers are
brought together and it's called
dehydration because I've just
highlighted two h's and an O It's called
dehydration because in this process
water is going to be removed and you
know the formula for water is H2O two H
is in an O so here we go three two one
notice how a water molecule was lost
and those two monomers were bonded
together they were built or synthesized
to make a larger molecule and that's
where the word synthesis comes from
let's do that one more time
let's bring in this third monomer and
again it's a dehydration reaction
because I've highlighted h2h as in a no
this is going to be water in three two
one
so water molecule is removed and the
monomer all three monomers have been
bonded together to make one larger
polymer that's a dehydration synthesis
reaction
now in the world of carbohydrates the
monomers are called monosaccharides so
here's three monosaccharides they're
brought together and in a dehydration
reaction water is removed and those two
monosaccharides have been bonded
together this is now a disaccharide but
let's bring in the third monosaccharide
in a dehydration synthesis reaction
there's the 82h is in an O the water is
removed and all three have been bonded
together to make a larger polysaccharide
in the world of proteins the monomers
are called amino acids so here's a
couple amino acids that are brought
together there's the two h's in the O
water is removed and the two amino acids
have been bonded together let's do that
for the third amino acid the third amino
acid is brought over 2H is in an O form
water water is removed and all three
amino acids have been bonded as one
larger polypeptide and eventually this
polypeptide would twist and fold and
wrap to become a protein
in the world of nucleic acids many
nucleotides will Barn to make a nucleic
acid so let's bring together two
nucleotides there's two h's in an O
water is removed and the two nucleotides
are bonded together let's do that one
more time to add the third nucleotide is
delivered two H is in an O water is
removed and all three nucleotides have
been bonded as one larger nucleic acid
and in the world of lipids lipids are
actually built from one part glycerol
and maybe uh two or three fatty acids in
this case there's two fatty acids and so
look at the first fatty acid it comes
over by the glycerol and notice two H is
in an O water is removed and the fatty
acid has bonded to the glycerol let's do
that one more time
the fatty acid comes over and two H is
in an o and a dehydration synthesis
reaction water is removed and now this
entire unit is now a lipid one larger
lipid so dehydration synthesis builds
larger molecules out of smaller parts
so in the blue side again is dehydration
synthesis in the summary picture you can
see three monomers are being built into
a single polymer let's focus our
attention on the bottom labeled
hydrolysis
this is a chemical reaction it's really
just the opposite that breaks down a
larger polymer into multiple monomers so
in my animation here we're going to see
that Hydro should imply the addition of
a water molecule
and lysis means to break down so with
the use of water watch what happens to
the monomer on the left three two one
the monomer on the left has been broken
away from the others this is a
hydrolysis reaction let's do that again
let's add another hydro hydro for water
and lysis means to break down three two
one the monomers have been broken apart
so we started with a single polymer
which has been broken down into three
individual monomers
now if we're looking at carbohydrates
this is how a single polysaccharide
that's what we have here we have one
large polysaccharide but with the
addition of a water molecule can be
broken down into monosaccharides let's
do that again with the addition of
another water molecule we can break
those two apart so now we have three
monosaccharides that were broken down
from the one starting polysaccharide
so in the case of a polypeptide now
that's what we have here we have a
single polypeptide one larger
polypeptide that can be broken down into
the individual amino acids and so with
the addition of a water molecule the
amino acid on the left can be broken
apart from the others and let's do that
one more time with the addition of a
water molecule the others Amino the
other amino acids have been broken apart
so we started with one single
polypeptide but now we have three
individual amino acids again that is a
hydrolysis reaction
in the case of nucleic acids a single
nucleic acid that's what we have right
here one larger nucleic acid can be
broken down into many nucleotide
monomers with the addition of water the
nucleotide on the left can be broken
apart from the others let's do that one
more time with the addition of water the
other two nucleotides can be broken so
we started with a single nucleic acid
and we ended up with three nucleotides
and lastly the same is true for lipids
one single lipid can be broken down
that's what we have right here we have
one larger lipid but it can be broken
down into the glycerol and the fatty
acids with the addition of a water
molecule three two one the fatty acid on
the bottom has been broken away let's do
that one more time with the addition of
a water molecule now the fatty acid on
top has been broken away so the glycerol
and the two fatty acids have been broken
apart in a hydrolysis reaction
so here's a little practice quiz and if
you want pause the video try to answer
these questions I hope you found this
video helpful thank you for watching